recently I sat down with the New South
Wales Center for Education Statistics
and evaluation they interviewed me for a
podcast that they recorded about
teaching mathematics the whole interview
was also videos so I'm really sharing
some of the videos from the interview
online now because the interview was
really focused on teachers I'm not gonna
putting all the videos here I'm gonna be
sharing them in my second channel and
I've got links in the description to all
of that but I thought since I know that
a lot of teachers view this channel I'd
share with you the first video which is
about why I chose to teach mathematics
so I hope you enjoy this and if you're
interested in more head over to the
second channel for a look there are two
answers to this question of why
mathematics the first one is just a
practical one so I went into teaching I
wanted to pursue this from around your
eleven twelve is where it sort of
crystallized into my mind and I thought
look I want to marry up two things what
what I'm good at and also what I think
matters in life and it's tricky to find
those as a teenager in school I quickly
realize that I love to see people learn
I love to see people grow it's what
gravitated me towards secondary because
I feel as though you walk into high
school and you're the this tiny little
blob with a bag bigger than you are and
you don't know how to do anything let
alone make decisions for your life and
then by the time you leave you're an
adult you're making choices you're
putting yourself on a trajectory to
decide the course of your life which is
quite amazing I love seeing that change
and so number one teaching but I sort of
didn't know really what subject I would
go towards I thought what I'm good at
English in history oh I enjoyed being my
music in agriculture classes with some
of my best teachers but for me I went to
Judy and I was at the enrollment day and
the Associate Dean of the University of
Sydney he walked along and he looked me
up and down and looked at my transcript
for all my subjects he said you should
be a maths teacher
you know you've obviously you've got a
background that you can do this there's
this immense need and because I just
wanted to be in a place where I could
serve students serve a community and be
maximally useful
that's the direction that I went in but
aside from that practical reason of
alright well I guess here's where I can
be beneficial people the longer I've
taught mathematics the more I've come to
see it's a thing of immense practical
usefulness it's a lens for seeing the
world and gain new perspective on things
and it also is in its own way beautiful
our thing to be appreciated there are
patterns all around us that just kind of
fly past us that we don't notice them
but mathematics gives us the tools to
understand what's really going on
[Music]